let's figure out what 11 and 12 16 minus
5 and 8 16 is and then we might have to
simplify it down to lowest terms so the
way i like to do these is to kind of
separate out the whole number part of
the mixed numbers from the fractional
part so i can rewrite this number right
over here as 11 plus 12 over 16. and
from that i am going to subtract and
i'll put parentheses here because i'm
going to break this part open i'm going
to subtract i'm going to subtract 5 plus
8 over
16. 5 and 8 16 same thing as 5 plus 8 16
but i have to remember i'm subtracting
it i'm subtracting this whole thing so i
can rewrite it as i'll rewrite this part
plus 12 over 16
and if i'm and i'm subtracting 5 plus 8
16 so i can distribute the negative sign
so it's going to be minus 5
minus 5 negative 1 times 5 and then
negative 1 times positive 8 16 so it's
going to be minus
minus 8 over 16
minus 8 over 16. and then i like to do
the whole number of parts separately and
then the fractional parts separately so
let's do the whole number of parts we
have 11 minus 5. i'll write it here 11
minus 5. we'll do that part that's the
whole number part and then we have plus
plus
12 16. let me do this in pink maybe plus
12 16
12 16 minus 8 16
minus 8 over 16
and 11 minus 5 is 6
and i have 6 plus and then our
denominators are the same here so we're
going to get something over 16
and 12 minus 8 is 4. so this is the same
thing as 6 plus 4 over 16 which is the
same thing as writing is a mixed number
6 and 4 16
6 and 4 16. and this is the right
quantity but we can simplify it 4 over
16 can be simplified both the numerator
and the denominator are divisible by
four they both have the factor four so
let's divide both the numerator and
denominator by four divided by four
divided by four since we're dividing by
the same thing we're not changing its
quantity and so this is equal to
we still have the whole number part 6
but the fraction part is now 1
1 over 4. so we get 6 and 1 4.